Denise Nye County deputies say the man
who tried to kidnap and kill an elderly
woman in Pahrump has a history with the
victim's family and that the attack on
her was an act of Revenge these are new
surveillance photos of the accused
attacker Ryan Sanders and his accomplice
Richard Duncan authorities say Sanders
attacked the 74-year-old woman in the
early morning of November 22nd they tied
her up and forced her into a car
deputies say Sanders then picked up
Duncan and drove to an abandoned RV
where they assaulted her again
investigators say the woman eventually
escaped got help from a neighbor Sanders
facing several new charges tonight
including sexual assault and battery as
well as kidnapping and attempted murder
charges a nationwide warrant has been
issued for his arrest Nye County
deputies also believed that his
13-year-old son Ryan Jr is with him they
think Sanders may have shaved since
disappearing
sheriff's deputies have arrested the
other suspect in this case Richard
Duncan who is we're told cooperating in
that investigation